okay so
i'm going to briefly recap what we
discussed and then sort of talk about
a number of different applications uh
ranging from like work
exercising credit card savings behavior
drinking smoking uh fertilizer use and
so on
and then uh um that'll spill into the
next lecture or
go into next lecture as well i'm gonna
sort of summarize where we are what do
we know about time preferences what have
you learned
what's useful from what have you learned
for the world and what things might be
still
up for investigation okay so what
happened so far is like i showed you
a simple model of exponential discounts
discounting again that's the workhorse
model
of discounting and economics is one of
the most successful and most important
models that people have written down in
economics the solo model etc like many
sort of different important models
thinking about long run growth and so on
use this particular
model so it's been tremendously
important and successful
it has different implications that we
discussed at length both in class and
lecture and in recitation which is
constant discounting
dynamic consistency and no demand for
commitment we discussed some evidence
that shows that these assumptions these
implications are not warranted
and then we talked about a different
version of this model or like an
extension if you want of that model
which is the quasi-hyperbolic
discounting model
which adds an additional parameter that
measures people's
present bias or present focus as people
call it sometimes these days
which allows us to be more flexible and
be able to look at
short run and long run discounting in
the same model
as in like there's one parameter of beta
that measures people's short run
discount factor
and another parameter delta which is
close to one often
that measures the long run discount
factor that makes the model more
flexible
and we're able to explain some phenomena
that might be hard to explain
otherwise any questions
on that so far or last time or the like
okay so then next we talked about
sophistication versus naivete
so this is the issue that we discussed
before which is um
present bias um creates time and
consistency right when thinking about
the future we want to be patient
when the time actually comes when the
future actually arrived uh
we we are impatient so then the key
question you might ask is like well do
people understand their time
inconsistency
we talked about two different extreme
assumptions or versions of this one is
full naivete
which is the idea that the person does
not realize that she will change her
mind
when thinking about the future she
thinks she's going to follow through on
her favorite plan
when the future comes she will be
patient but then of course
uh the future arrives and surprises
happen and the person is surprised by
their own
present bias and sort of there's false
optimism about future patients
and sort of the uh over and over again
the person might say this time
is different um second a second extreme
assumption is a
full sophistication that is perfect for
sight the person actually understands
the beta perfectly well
and understands that she on the future
might not stick to the plans that she
has and might change her mind
so she does sort of her best given the
future selves anticipated
changes in behavior so taken into
account as a constraint what the person
will do in the future
the person optimizes uh that way
there's no surprises about future
present bias the person has rational
expectations
okay those are the two broad extreme
assumptions
that we discussed now how can we tell
how can we actually
tell so if i if you wanted to to to know
about
uh your friend and try to understand is
this person not even so or sophisticated
how can we actually tell
what that's the case what do we do
what data could you collect from your
friend or from people that you see
and what exactly would you collect um
right so one thing you can do is collect
the person's beliefs you can ask them
what are you going to do in the future
and if the person mispredicts what
they're going to be in the future in
particular if the person thinks they're
going to be more patient in the future
than they actually are
so if they think their beta in the
future is higher than it actually is
that would that would suggest at least
some naivete
right what else could we
could we uh elicit
yesterday
exactly so if you offered them
commitment devices and we said here's a
commitment device you can change your
future behavior in certain ways that
make certain behaviors in the future
more expensive
so for example you might tell your
friend or
your friend might offer to you if i
don't do the problem set until
friday 5 pm because you want to have
like fun friday night
i'm gonna pay you a hundred dollars um
now
um if you uh make that choice or if
somebody offers you that option to like
pay them hundred dollars in case you
haven't done the problem set by
friday five pm uh that choice does make
doesn't make any sense if the if the
person is an exponential discounter
that person only makes sense if you are
present bias or if you have self-control
problems in some way
and you must be sophisticated in some
sense so it must must indicate some form
of sophistication
to be clear it doesn't indicate perfect
sophistication
you might be only partially
sophisticated but at least it indicates
some form of sophistication we're going
to talk about partial sophistication
in a bit the same awareness issue
does not arise with exponential
discounting why is that so in some sense
if you thought about like if you have
looked at like the exponential
discounting model
there's nothing about sophistication and
navitate there's no parameter that
measures that and why is that
why do we need like a delta hat or
whatever
yes
right exactly so the whole issue only
arises because there's time and
consistency the future self
wants different things that the current
self does in the exponential discounting
model there's no such issue there's no
time inconsistency so the future self
will always do what the current self
actually wants to do unless
circumstances change
so we don't need any parameter that sort
of looks at like how much is the future
self deviating
because that's not even an issue in the
first place
okay so then um we talked about sort of
extreme assumptions so these are extreme
assumptions on the
on the two ends one is like full naivete
you're entirely naive you just cannot
uh imagine that your beta in the future
will be different from one that's full
naivete
and then there is um the other extreme
assumption which is full sophistication
which is beta hat equals beta right
essentially as like you understand
entirely what's going on with your
future
um beta but of course there's a whole
range in between from beta to
uh to one uh that beta hat could
could take and that's what we refer to
as like partial naivety
that is to say beta hat measures the the
beliefs about future beta
the extreme cases um are useful to think
about but
presumably the truth is somewhere in
between so the intermediate case might
be sort of the most relevant one
uh which is beta hat is between beta
and one so that is to say the individual
understands that they will experience
present bias in the future so i know
that i have some
present bias in the future as an example
say
my beta might be 0.6 i might think i
understand to some degree that my future
beta is not one but i might think it's
like 0.8 or the like
so understand that i will be present
biased in the future
and but i underestimate the degree of
present bias in the future and so
[Music]
if i'm partially naive and this is what
maya was saying earlier
i i might demand commitment devices
anyway
i might understand i have a i have a
problem in the future so i want some
commitment devices
but i could also overcome it i could so
demand commitment devices are actually
not useful for me
why is that because i sort of
underestimate how bad my self-control
problem is i understand there's a
self-control problem somebody offers me
a commitment device that's fairly weak
i say great that's going to help me i'm
going to that's going to help me follow
through
but then surprise my self-control
problems actually worse than i
anticipated and then i have a commitment
device and i'm actually failing with
that commitment device because the
self-control problem happens to be worse
than anticipated any questions on this
we're gonna uh uh talk tomorrow about
like um
a little bit about like solving problems
with partial naivete we talked about
solving problems with full naivete and
full sophistication
partial navitation is a little bit
trickier because it sort of requires
iterating forwards and backwards
uh we talk about this briefly um
tomorrow
okay so now demand for commitment we
already talked about this before
here's sort of a formal definition it's
defined as an arrangement entered into
by an agent who restricts his and her
future choices by making certain choices
more expensive perhaps infinitely
expensive
right that's to say at the margin you
might sort of pay for something
that might make your restrict your
choices or make your choices in the
future more expensive
if it's like not available at all you
think you can think of this as like the
price is like infinite
right so i make i i don't want to eat
donuts tomorrow i can make donuts more
expensive more and more expensive if
it's infinitely expensive doughnuts are
just not available
to me so now of course
as we said before time and consistent
preferences uh the self stiffer and this
is again repetition
uh selves differ between what you want
today versus in the future
you might sort of worry about
misbehaving in the future if you
understand that you might
uh want to discipline your future self
by demanding a commitment device
okay so who are viewers using commitment
devices or can you give me an example of
a commitment device that they have used
in the past successful or not
yes
does it work
i should try that um yes i've been
i've been uh
right exactly so that's an example of a
commitment device that's sort of partial
in some ways it's not sort of
strong enough so either you can sort of
substitute to like you know firefox or
whatever like another browser
you can substitute your phone you can
substitute your friend's phone even and
so on
or you know you might just actually be
able to turn it off yourself
but you can circumvent i think there's
sort of some apps that have sort of
options that don't allow you to do that
at all but you guys are like
a lot of cs majors so maybe you can get
around that as well
any other examples yes
so what do you do actually then so
what's your commitment device
i guess it's like making the choice to
eat something else like more expensive
because i have to like go back to the
grocery store
but so what but how do you commit then
or like what's
restricting your options
but like so so so you know that you're
going to do that in the future
potentially so now how do you
avoid or change your future behavior can
you sort of
incentivize yourself or can you make
sure so
another version of that would be like so
what people often do is like
um when they buy for example potato
chips so they're like they buy really
small bags
and part sort of knowing that like if
they buy a big bag which actually would
be cheaper
they would just eat it all so then you
have like only very small portions and
then you know
if you want another one you have to sort
of go to the store and buy more
so that's like a version it's sort of a
version of a commitment device where
essentially you commit yourself to
if you want to eat more potato chips in
the future you have to go back to the
store as opposed to having like a big
bag that you can just consume in one
session yeah any other examples
uh yes
i see and so that's interesting so yeah
exactly so like um
you know credits it's interesting
because in some sense in some other
settings carrying cash is sort of
not helping but you're saying like
instead of having a credit card you can
spend usually
as much as you like depending on what
your credit limit is you might say i'm
going to go
out with 100 and like once i've spent
100
i'm not going to spend more i have to
sort of go back home or or the like
and then i might sort of not give in to
temptations the reason why i was
hesitating a little bit is like in
developing countries in part in some
settings where i work
you know lots of people have lots of
cash on hand from like their work for
example
cycle rickshaw drivers they would have
um a lot of cash on hand
because they get like trips if they get
paid for every single trip
and then they have lots of cash on hand
it's actually quite bad because then
they can spend it on lots of things
any day and there you know having it in
their liquid or their savings account or
the like
would be a a different form of
commitment device that might help them
there was more um
and uh does it work yeah
wow interesting i've not heard this what
is it called
i see yeah you can see like uh
yeah it depends a little bit i guess um
uh
yeah so when asked does it work does it
work on average or what's being shown
or you know how costly is it to fail but
it sounds like at least for some people
that's in fact
um effective yeah
there are some accounts where you can
put money to take the money out
right in fact a lot of retirement
accounts in the us and many places have
penalties for early withdrawal right so
a lot of like
uh um many employers that offer like
401k and other savings
uh vehicles essentially that's like a
retirement
uh sort of tax deferred retirement
savings often sort of subsidized by the
employer but often one
one condition is that like you have to
pay a 10 or something penalty to
withdraw it
similarly i think for some savings
account that's sort of similar and the
idea is very much like
helping you uh uh resist temptations to
like uh change your plans you're gonna
plan for retire like saving for
retirement or something else
but in fact you might sort of withdraw
early um uh if you're tempted
and then usually the penalty is only
like something like 10 or the leg
because when people have actual shocks
like you know health shocks or other
issues
they want to be able to take out the
money at some penalty
um so you don't want to have it to be
entirely illiquid
because that would you know that would
be bad for them any other
example yes uh i have an alarm
clock on my phone where i have to take a
picture of something
so i'll like get up and go to the
bathroom and take a picture of this
thing
does it work no i take the picture like
a rectangle
i see fair enough um does it work
sometimes
yeah sometimes i see yeah so they're the
issue in some sense is like
if it doesn't work then you kind of like
worse off than before because you slept
like worse
and then you would have otherwise and
you know um there's no benefit of you
getting actually up
yeah one more yes uh would like
societally implied
commitment like no shave november or
like some sort of variance on that
of what exactly no shape november or
like experience of this would that
imply commitment device yeah i mean i
think the
the um in some sense there's often uh
some commitment devices are essentially
sort of public attention of the leg
where people are announcing one way or
the other publicly which is kind of what
you were saying earlier
where society in some sense has some
influence where people sort of would say
they would publicly declare that they're
going to lose weight they would publicly
declare that they're going to
save money and so on and then there
would be sort of social shaming in some
way or the other
um to do that now uh what you want so in
some cases if it's just society imposing
things on people
that's not enough what you want is a
person actively sort of making some
announcement or some statements
with the goal of like making it more
costly not to follow through
okay so um as i said before demand for
commitment requires at least some
partial
sophistication i have some examples for
you here one is like stick i don't know
if you have any of has any of you used
sick
no okay so sticker's a website
founded by an academic dean carland and
co-authors
what stic does is it's a commitment
device that works in some sense
in the way i was saying before for
example um
uh what you if you want to sort of
commit to certain behaviors for example
if i wanted to finish a
paper draft by friday night i would have
to find a referee i would for example
ask aaron to be my referee and i would
say aaron
i'm going to give you my credit card
information and
if i don't finish the paper
by friday night i'm going to pay a
hundred dollars either to aaron or to
some charity
it could be anti-charity it could be the
pro-smoking pro whatever um
uh a society um the money is gonna be uh
uh
gone and so then friday night comes
aaron is the referee
who uh i can then sort of uh decide or
will decide then whether i have actually
followed through did i actually write a
draft is there an actual paper um that's
done
and uh if it's done then nothing happens
i don't have to pay any money
if it's not done the money is gone and
since
the credit card information is on the
website um they can actually just
withdraw that money
what's the problem with this commitment
device potentially
yes yes
exactly so like i tried to use this a
few times in grad school
and my friend was my referee and then
you know friday night would come and
then i would sort of just convince my
friend to like i'll pay you dinner if
you if you uh
if you um uh uh let me get through so
you need a very good friend who is
actually sort of then insisting and sort
of credible
uh uh potentially or you know your enemy
could be your referee if you if you want
it who's happy sort of then to take your
uh money
but i think it's worth trying you can
try it out and see whether it works i'd
love to hear some thoughts on whether it
works uh
uh or not um there's clocky which i
think is um uh is a uh
uh coming out of mit it's a it's an
alarm clock that runs away which is kind
of similar to
to um what you mentioned earlier um
there's also taki which is little
enclosed that jumps around and you have
to sort of find it
um there's sort of um some forms of uh
this is a
fake alarm clocks i don't think it
actually exists where essentially if you
don't get up and press a button
on your on your alarm you essentially
give money to charity or anti-charities
if you want
there's a thing called ant abuse which
is quite interesting which is um
a drug that essentially interferes with
the metabolism of alcohol
so this is some people have trouble
metabolizing alcohol anyway so when they
drink they're flush they turn uh
they get headaches uh they have to throw
up and
feel unwell and so on so for them
drinking is very unpleasant as it is and
turns out there's a drug
that can actually sort of reproduce
those kinds of
behaviors or feelings um and it's
essentially you can take it and then for
the next 24 to 48 hours you will not be
able to metabolize alcohol there's also
versions of that that are sort of
implants for like a month so the like
but essentially they make alcohol
consumption very unpleasant and this is
sort of
meant to to help people who have
problems with alcohol consumption
uh that like if you want don't want to
drink tomorrow or
two days from now or the like um or the
next month you can take it
and then commit to to not doing that and
then alcohol consumption becomes very
unpleasant
uh when when consuming alcohol anyway
it's a little bit dangerous and or it
can be quite dangerous if people then
drink anyway because they're sort of an
alcohol
anti-abuse sort of a reaction that's
quite dangerous
um so it hasn't been particularly
successful in part also because people
sort of fall off the bandwagon
so if you are essentially take that
daily or like every second day
what happens then is that people start
wanting to drink and then they just stop
taking the abuse and then have to sort
of just wait it out for 24 hours
or the leg until the drug is out of the
system and then they um
drink anyway but in principle it's like
the ideal commitment device because
essentially the only reason for you to
take this
uh this drug would be to reduce your
future um
drinking um there's also sort of various
versions of like self-control devices
which essentially
either restrict certain websites that
you can go to you can restrict yourself
or it restricts them to certain hours or
you can sort of give yourself a budget
for a number of hours that you use
certain websites for
any questions
so um i also have a video of commitment
devices which i'm not sure that the
audio actually works so you have to try
this out if not i'll show it to you
tomorrow okay so as you can see i um
i think we can learn a lot from uh
watching movies and i love tv so um
um what can we learn from this i think
they can actually we can learn a lot
about sort of
commitment devices and whether they work
and why they work or why they might not
work
so what did we what did we learn
yes
right so just making like future choices
more expensive
might not be enough right i might sort
of say i might have self-control
problems
now i'm going to increase the price of
my future behavior
but that doesn't mean that it actually
works it might just be more costly and i
have to climb up the ladder or whatever
but then i might still eat the cookie
and that's not
helping what else did we learn
[Music]
yeah but i think you have to find
the penalty a balance
right exactly so what they did
essentially they made the penalty or
they essentially made the price of
cookies infinitely high they just sort
of gave them away to the birds
now they don't have any cookies at all
and sort of not they're gonna eat
no cookies whatsoever which is kind of
not what they wanted either
right i think another lesson is that
once you've made one of these commitment
devices so costly
that you can actually just
yes exactly that's what i was saying
earlier you might sort of restrict your
browser you might sort of like shut down
chrome or even like your entire laptop
but then if you start surfing on your
phone that's not really helping so
sometimes there's like substitution to
different potential
either sort of goods or devices and so
on or technologies
uh that might sort of undo your um
commitment device so they need to be
sort of like foolproof in some sense
in the sense of like being able to not
substitute you to other things
okay so first substitution across
temptation goes to mitigate the
usefulness of commitment
if essentially you have like other vices
or other things you're going to do
instead
then it's not really helpful to shut
down one thing uh uh
only so you have to think about like if
i don't do the
behavior that i'm trying to prevent is
this sort of other behaviors that i
might gonna substitute to towards
um uh and then it's not going to be
helpful um
either now it's also helpful to think
about like what is it actually what is
it actually required for
a commitment device to be helpful to a
person so first kind of obviously in
some ways the person needs to have some
self-control problem
in the first place this needs to be
something that in the future some
behavior you want to change
second there needs to be some
sophistication right like frog and toad
they kind of know that they're going to
eat too many cookies they need to sort
of understand that
third and this is what um we said
earlier um the equipment commitment
needs to be effective right we need to
have something that's sort of strong
enough
to be able to help us um overcome our
self-control problems
and then fourth it needs to be the
person needs to actually think that the
device is effective right if i sort of
don't have faith in myself i think this
is not useful
then i'm never gonna uh uh take it up or
conversely i guess there's issues
potentially with like
uh naivete there's two things that
naivete could do
so one uh part and i've had what i was
already talking about before
which is to say i might be naive in a
sense i'm saying like i know i don't
have a if i'm fully naive i might sort
of think i don't have a self-control
problem it's not really bad so i don't
really need a commitment device in the
first place
that's one version where i sort of under
demand commitment where i say like i
don't actually need it
it's not helpful for me anyway in the
future i will behave so i might not
demand commitment
another version is to say i might
actually demand commitment devices where
i over commit myself in a sense like i
think the commitment device is actually
helpful
well in fact it is not so like frog and
toad we're not doing that in some sense
they sort of like understood
to some degree at least um uh uh pretty
well what they're gonna do in the future
i think they sort of underestimated the
substitution in this case in the sense
of like they thought
like giving the uh the cookies uh to the
birds would be sort of helpful
but in fact then they sort of
underestimated the uh the substitution
and in the end you know they're going to
be worse off because now he's going to
like make the cake anyway and then eat a
lot of cake
he could have as well just eaten the
cookies in the first place
any questions on this
okay so now um let me sort of turn
towards some like academic papers and
sort of actual
empirical um uh setups so this is the
paper that you um uh uh
uh hope i'll read which is um ariely and
wharton brock then ariel was actually a
professor here at
um at sloane at the end a bunch of
experiments mostly with
mit students at sloan mbas
uh and so these are 51 executives at
sloan
these are sort of highly incentivized
individuals in the sense that they take
classes
if they don't if they fail a class if
they do badly in a class they have to
actually pay for it themselves so they
really are incentivized to do um
well they had to submit three papers in
the class they get a one percent grade
penalty for late submissions which is um
uh quite a bit there were two groups
group a had even the space deadlines
group b
had the option to set their own
deadlines and
[Music]
now the first sort of
result here is that there was demand for
commitment in the sense that like um
68 of people chose um deadlines prior to
the last week so when given the option
when do you want to set your deadlines
over the course of the semester
68 of people chose deadlines they were
not uh
the last week why is that demand for
commitment
yes more choices
exactly like you there's no reason
unless you have sort of issues with
self-control the like you just make it
essentially costly for you to submit
late
if you're worried about submitting
everything late that's a good thing for
you to do
and it might help you again notice that
it requires some sophistication you need
to sort of understand your future
behavior to do that now what they find
is like they find no late submissions
which is interesting by itself
but in particular they find that like
group a has higher grades than
group b okay group a is the group that
has evenly spaced deadlines
uh uh compared to group b that has the
option to set their own deadlines
it is consistent with self-control
problems in the sense that people set
their own deadlines
that are early what else is it
consistent
what do we learn from that what do we
learn from the fact that group a does
better than group b
yes
um yeah so in some sense the the
commitment devices that people chose for
themselves was um not strong enough or
like weaker
than the evenly spaced deadlines now
notice the easily spread
space deadlines are in the choice set of
people like if you choose your own
deadlines
you can just say i'm choosing evenly
spaced deadlines and you should do as
well if you're perfectly sophisticated
you would do as well as the
group a but the fact that the group's
group b is doing like worse sort of
tells us that people are not optimally
setting deadlines
either they don't there's a fraction of
people who don't choose any deadlines
you know there's at least
32 percent of people who sort of say my
deadlines are all at the end so maybe
these are naive people
or even among the people who set
deadlines they might choose deadlines
that are like further back in the
semester
and they do worse than in the evenly
spaced deadlines so what
did we learn so people do set early
deadlines quite a few of them
so we learn about um people are at least
partially or some people are
sophisticated
but they're only partially sophisticated
they don't set the deadlines
optimally which is sort of consistent
with people being naive at least in some
way
yeah i was wondering does it make sense
to try to find a difference between
not adequately measuring your commitment
right that's a great question so the
question is um
so there's two things that are perhaps
uncertain when you think about the
future one is
your present bias your preference
parameter about like
uh uh how much work you're gonna put in
like today versus tomorrow and how much
you're gonna procrastinate
a second question is about like your
beliefs about your effort costs in some
way or the other which is like
how costly is it for you to actually do
the problem set or write the paper and
so on
and you might underestimate how tedious
it is to do there's sort of a large
literature on what's called the planning
fallacy people always
plan too many things and like think
whatever their plan
uh takes uh shorter than it actually
does or put differently
things always take longer than people
think when they make plans
and the odd thing is that also is the
case even if you take that into account
so in some sense even if you're aware of
the planning fallacy and you plan and
you know that people are gonna things
are gonna take longer
somewhat oddly enough people are even
taking longer even if you take that into
account
but anyway so um the question is kind of
like how can we separate
um um uh uh that
i think that's from this evidence we
cannot separate this they sort of like
clean our experiments that are more
careful about this
in some sense the if it were just about
like underestimating effort costs
then you would not set your own
deadlines necessarily like
the setting early deadlines is
consistent with like self-control
issues but just from the performance
you're right that could just be people
underestimate
effort costs as well in general i think
this is hard to separate in many
situations the key part about the
self-control problems about the
time inconsistency is a demand for
commitment which sort of reveals that
people have some form of self-control
problems
related to time preferences any other
question
so now uh there's one concern is the two
sessions are not randomly assigned why
is that a problem potentially so we have
you know like
we have 51 executives 25 or something 26
are in one and 25 or another
but they're not randomly assigned across
the two sessions
yes
[Music]
right so there could be sort of like
selection people sort of switch sessions
i am not sure recitations i'm not sure
that's actually
uh possible but setting that so that's
surely one problem like selection into
the different groups
setting that aside what other problem do
we have
yes if the two sessions are at different
times and there's some advanced classes
exactly there could just be other um
sorry this is a version of what you were
saying earlier sorry misunderstood a
little bit
exactly there could be like uh people
are for other reasons than the actual
treatment
uh people might uh one session is early
one is late one is on thursday one is on
friday
uh one has a better ta one has a worse
ca or whatever people might sort of
select into different
so the characteristics that people um
have when they select into
when they end up in session a versus
session b might be different
so what you compare is essentially
different types of people
second there's only two sessions of
sections that's essentially an issue of
like
sample size and statistics we're going
to talk in one of the recitations about
that in more detail
but essentially the bottom line is that
like if you randomize
ads or if you were to randomize which
they haven't even done here but if you
were to randomize
at the level of a section then if you
only have like two sections that's
essentially
uh not enough because you might face
correlated shocks
what is that for example it might be
like one ta is better than the other and
one
one class a or b the group might do much
better than the other
not because of the deadline policy but
just because of the ta
or again it could be that like the
recitation is early in the morning or
and people don't pay attention or
whatever there might be many other
things happening
and so on so in some sense the sample
size is a
too small to start with 50 people is
very small for an experiment
two if you randomize or if you if you
have only like two treatment groups
um uh you need like more clusters as
people call it
more sort of um items of randomization
overall so now um there's a second
experiment that they did to deal with
the first issue this was sort of like um
again not a huge sample but uh you know
somewhat better
it's uh 60 people and now it's like
randomized
into three treatment groups one is
evenly spaced deadlines b
is like no deadlines three is like
self-imposed deadlines
this is now like a proofreading exercise
over 21 days
this is now randomized at the individual
level so it's not in groups anymore so
we get a little bit away from this
cluster issue that we had before
now what is an exponential discount to
do in terms of
performance what do we predict uh what's
going to happen
so like a person with beta equals one
what do we say
is going to happen to the performance of
these groups
yes which one all of them or
so let's start with the self-imposed
deadlines and the no deadlines
what kinds of deadlines is the
exponential discount are going to set
none somebody said yes and
yeah like why would you set a deadline
you don't need a deadline you're gonna
just do it whenever it's it's best to do
there might be some you might get sick
or like some other shocks might appear
in
the course of the semester so deadlines
will just restrict yourself
so you will not self-impose any
deadlines
so early deadlines essentially just
limit flexibility that's not helpful to
do
you don't need to sort of self-impose
any deadlines
and then you might sort of do weekly
worse uh or
in group a you might do it a little bit
worse because essentially uh
shocks might happen or the like there's
no reason to believe that like if you
restrict your option you might do better
group a might happen to do as well as c
and b but at least they're going to be
weakly worse
in part because you know people get sick
around deadlines and the like
okay so what about a sophisticated
person uh
uh with you know beta hat equals beta
smaller than one
so so the the evenly spaced deadline
will do
better or worse than no deadlines to
start with
huh and why is that um
exactly exactly so that should help and
then the self-imposed deadlines
there you know you can optimally set the
deadlines you could probably do at least
weekly better than the evenly spaced
ones
because you might also take into account
you know some constraints that you have
in the semester
like your family is visiting or the lake
uh that might be sort of like you
you so even the space deadline might not
be optimal because of that
if you self-impose them and you're
perfectly sophisticated you can take
into that into account
right so so you know deadlines can help
and you know
flexible deadlines tend to be uh
preferable because you can sort of take
into account your
uh individual specific costs that you
might
face okay what about the fully naive
person
yes so no deadlines deadline should be
the same because if you're fully
correct correct so as before the evenly
spaced deadline since the person has
beta smaller
some people have paid us more than one
the evenly spaced deadlines likely do
better or help people do better
unless they sort of like miss a lot of
deadlines anyway because of
procrastination but assuming the
deadline sort of helping people
space things out better they uh uh
they're gonna do better than the
no deadlines case and then the fully
naive person says why would i set any
deadlines i don't need any deadline
flexibility is good i'm gonna do it
early anyway of course that's not to
happen
but then essentially b is doing the same
as c because the person does not set any
deadlines
at all okay so now what about the
partially naive person
yes
can you say um sure so
i mean i guess like if they're
sufficiently sophisticated then it's
possible that c is better than a which
is better
but if they're like
[Music]
right so um i guess the answer is like
to some degree it depends
so we still have like a is better than b
so if people have beta smaller than one
the even space deadlines still as before
are going to do
uh somewhat better than the no deadlines
now
for the self-imposed deadlines
essentially two things can happen
one is like the person might actually
set some deadlines that happen to be
actually helpful if they're sufficiently
sophisticated
the deadlines might actually help at
least some people
but for some people they might set over
ambitious deadlines i say oh i'm going
to get it done all next week
well it turns out that actually not true
and then they sort of set two early
deadlines and then after rush or they
missed the deadline or the like they
might actually do worse
so there we have essentially no clear
predictions
some commitment should help so c could
be better than b but individuals might
also over commit so c might actually be
worse than b so that's essentially
there's no uh empirical
uh clear empirical um prediction any
questions on what i showed you here
yes
so you mean like a sub sample of people
who happen to choose evenly spaced
deadlines
yeah so the concerns
[Music]
um yeah so the issue there is
essentially so one thing
they were doing in the paper is to say
let's look at the people who set
evenly spaced deadlines and say when
they uh how are they doing compared to
people
um in the control group or the like the
problem with that is like
these people are selected in certain
ways like if i sort of just um uh
this is a subset of people that's
non-randomly selected they you know we
know that they chose certain deadlines
so in some sense we know that they're
different in some ways
compared to the average person in the
group and these could be people who are
like more productive less productive etc
and so on
so the clean design how you would do
that is essentially what you would do is
you would
ask people to
ask for the deadline choices and then
randomize them into different
deadline regimens so either they get
their choice or not so you can actually
estimate the treatment effect on those
kinds of people and then
look at uh are the even lease-based
deadlines are those
treatment effects of those people worse
or not but i worry that in that kind of
analysis what's non-random here or what
they're choosing is like a non-random
subset and compare that
with a control group they're sort of
that's correlated with other stuff
and that's not necessarily uh giving you
a causal um
effect having said that
um you know when you look at the um the
uh the evenly spaced deadlines they
could sort of make things worse in some
ways in the sense of like
even for people with data smaller than
one it could be that people miss the
deadlines because they're
procrastinating and so on and so forth
or like
they have some shocks of the lake so
it's not necessarily obvious that they
do better that's sort of all under some
assumptions
any other questions
okay so now what we find is like a is
doing better than c
is doing better than b so this is
essentially true for like errors um
detected it's true for delays and
submission it's also true for like
people's earnings in the
entire exercise so now what you have is
like a is better than c
is better than b so what is that
consistent with well it seems like it's
consistent with like some partial
naivete in some sense admittedly um
[Music]
uh the prediction of partial naivete is
a little bit loose in a sense that like
all we're saying is a is better than b
and uh you know uh
uh then the comparison with c could go
either way so sure it's consistent with
partial naivete
but it's also like only suggestive in
some sense because there's no clear
prediction uh in that
case however we can reject sort of like
the other
cases we can reject the exponential
discounting the sophisticated present
bias the fully sophisticated one
or the fully naive present biased person
because you know those predictions are
not
borne out so the only case that sort of
really is left is the um
partial naivete one so let me sort of
summarize what we saw
well um so the result is that deadline
setting improves performance
that is evidence of some present bias
being like essentially beta being
smaller than one
uh it's also um uh uh consistent with
partial naivete people set deadlines
which is consistent
the set early deadlines which shows some
demand for commitment some form of
sophistication
um then result two sort of says deadline
setting is suboptimal which sort of
suggests that
beta is smaller than uh beta hat or beta
hat is bigger than beta which sort of
means that essentially
people seem to underestimate the
self-control
problems that they have in the future so
that's sort of broadly speaking some
support
of the beta delta model with partial
naivete any questions on this paper
okay ah yes sorry good i was asked
so this is what i was discussing earlier
partial naivete meaning that
um let me just go back for a second
this was discussing here earlier partial
naivete meaning that
so we discussed two cases before which
was full naivete or full sophistication
full naivete meaning that beta hat
equals one
full sophistication meaning that beta
hat equals beta
and now if you sort of take a take the
case in between which is
where you see what you have here at the
bottom which is
beta hat equal is in the middle of beta
and one or in between beta and one
so essentially you understand that your
beta in the future is not one
but you sort of underestimate um uh
uh how small it is so you know as i said
before my beta might be 0.6
i might understand that my future beta
is not 1. so i understand it's smaller
than 1
but i might think it's like 0.8 or 0.9
which is to say i
overestimate my future beta to some
degree while i get it right that it's
not 1
i might sort of get it wrong in the
sense of like saying it's not 0.6 in
fact
i might think it's higher than that okay
okay let me go back to okay so
so in some sense these are nice
experiments and they're useful
experiments to help us sort of
understand is the evidence for this
model
is the evidence for some of the
predictions that we have
but it's still fairly contrived in the
sense of like it's pretty
it's kind of like especially in the
second experiment it's kind of like a
lab experiment that like
really what we want to know is like in
the real world or commitment devices a
helpful in some sense do people want
them
and b are they actually improving
behaviors in certain ways should a firm
use commitment devices this is actually
helpful in proving
for improving a firm performance so
there's a very nice paper by supreme
court senator mulanathan and
michael kramer who sort of investigate
this question using
data entry workers in india so this is
um
a full-time job for people this is the
primary source of earnings
for these workers these are people who
are like sort of recruited as data entry
workers for the course of 13 months so
what like over a year as like a typical
data entry worker so sometimes there was
a job ad let's say we're looking for
data entry worker we have data to be
entered
people would answer that job ad and then
sort of start working
to do a data entry output is measured as
it is usually done in many data entry
companies by measuring the number of
accurate fields entered in a day
this is sort of measured by doing dual
entry as in to say that the data is
entered twice it's then matched with the
other person
and sort of the number of um errors or
discrepancies so sort of then
defined as an error rate and if the
error rate and the error rate sort of
uh you you match to different people
over time so i can sort of back out your
errate uh how good or bad you are
so people essentially incentivized to to
do to work fast
and incentivize to enter stuff uh
correctly
uh workers are paid a piece rate uh
using a with a weekly paycheck they're
paid once a week
um there's no restrictions on hours
people can show up whenever they like
they can stay for as many hours they
like on any given
day there are no penalties for absences
so you can just if you don't show up on
a given day nothing
happens this is what the data entry task
looks like there's essentially some data
this is kind of interesting this is data
coming from kenya
so michael kramer and senator malanathan
were working on some kenyan
data where they had like a huge amount
of data from kenya and sugarcane farmers
over the course of 30 years some records
historical records that they found
they wanted them to get entered so like
well how did we get them entered well
india is the place to do that
so they got them entered and then when
they sort of hired lots of people to
enter the data they thought well
why not run an experiment to learn about
self-control among workers
while doing that so what they would do
is they would show these like scanned
images of these pages
and then there's like a sort of like a
computer software pretty rudimentary
that way you can sort of enter
uh the fields in your data set
now the commandment device is um as a
dominated contract that looks as follows
so the as i told you before workers are
paid a peace rate w
uh it's a linear piece rate that's the
control contract for
their production so forever production
think of production is how much the
correct entries that you produce
for each correct entry that you make
you're going to get paid uh
w now the dominated contract looks as
this this is the red one that you see
here
which is until a target t i'll talk
about the target in a second
until the target t you paid w uh over
two which is like half as much as before
and as soon as you reach t and the
target you're going to be paid w for the
entire uh production that you make
why is this a commitment contract
so if i ask you to choose your target t
if you choose a positive target why is
this a commitment contract yes
right that's right so there's no value
of
um choosing this contract so if you're
an exponential discounter you might just
choose t equals zero
the reason being that there's no point
in like choosing a high target
who knows what's going to happen you
might get a headache your kid might get
sick the computer might not work or
whatever for whatever reason there might
be shocks uncertainty that might make
you not reach your target
and so if you choose a positive target
the only thing you can do from this
positive target is you see
you can do only worse right it's a
weekly dominated contract
in terms of like your payments so
there's no reason to actually do that
but why might the worker actually choose
it anyway
yes
so there's no really like schedules
right
exactly i might sort of just be like you
know slightly below t
or the like i might sort of be tempted
to go home
you know my friends call or whatever and
i might just not want to do it it might
be just a tedious day it might be really
hot
i have really goals to work a lot and
sort of i want to incentivize my future
self
to reach certain targets that's exactly
right
so um i think this is uh we already
said all of that workers can choose the
t in advance they can choose essentially
on the previous day they can choose t
equals zero they also have a
randomization of paydays to be able to
look at payday effects
what do i mean by that i told you like
workers are paid weekly
either and so they randomize the paydays
what they do is they randomize the
paydays to be tuesdays thursdays or
saturdays
so you can sort of allow for day of the
week fixed effects that's kind of
something sound interesting but
essentially you can look at uh
when a worker is paid in a given week
are they more or less productive on that
day compared to the previous days and so
on and so forth
what is the exponential discounting
model predict about paydays
or payday effects should you work harder
on a payday
yes
right exactly like your delta is like
0.95 or like
it doesn't really matter whether like
the the daily discounting should be
essentially close to there should be
essentially close to no discounting
between different days
you might have a yearly delta of 0.95 or
the like but then between today and
tomorrow today uh
two days and three days from now and so
on doesn't really matter so if i'm
working today
and i'm paid today it's the same as if
i'm working today and i'm paid in like
three days
however if i'm a quasi-hyperbolic
discounter well what's going to
be the case is like if i'm working on
sundays i'm working today
and i'm going to be paid today well then
i'm going to work harder maybe i get the
money right away
i can buy a nice meal my family is going
to be happier and so on and so forth
now notice that requires some form of
liquidity constraints
right and something they have a bunch of
cash anyway it doesn't really matter
whether i'm going to be paid today
versus tomorrow
but assuming that some workers are
liquidity constrained
essentially whether they paid today
versus tomorrow matters a lot when the
reward comes if you think about like
today it's like 10 a.m i'm typing and
typing now i think about like when do i
get the reward either it's on the payday
you're going to be paid at like 5 p.m
so you're gonna get essentially a nice
meal on the same day versus if you paid
in five days that's really far away
in the beta delta world your reward for
working hard
is coming much later okay so um
uh so you think you know
quasi-hyperbolic discounters would put
in higher efforts on paydays
assuming there's some form of liquidity
constraints
there should be close to no difference
between other days that depends a little
bit like what's the horizon of the beta
that we talked to
about before okay so now what do they
find in this paper
they find essentially three results the
first result is
there's demand for commitments there's
sort of people choose dominated
contracts
that is to say workers select dominated
contracts about 36 percent of the time
this is a lower bound um for the extent
of time consist
time and consistency for three reasons
reason one is some workers might be
naive they might sort of think you know
they don't need any targets well in fact
they would benefit from targets so they
you know they might under under invest
in this sort of technology
second people might think this
commitment device is actually
ineffective in a sense saying like look
this is sort of what we're talking about
with the frog and the toad
there might be they might have like time
inconsistency issues it might just not
be a strong enough commitment device
and so then you know if i have a day
where i just don't want to work
then if that's not going to get you over
the target well then
uh i might not choose this commitment
device not because i'm not
uh i don't have like present bias but
because it's just
not effective enough of a punishment for
me uh to do
number three is people might prefer
flexibility and they're risk averse
these are issues like you know they
might have like children that get sick
they might have headaches and so on
there might just be risks that's
unrelated to their present biases like
the computers might be bad so like they
had different computers at different
speed you might
end up with a really bad computer and
then you know you might not reach your
target
that's nothing to do with self-control
or present bias but rather with sort of
external risk and
if you're really worried about risk then
you might not choose a positive target
either
second they find offering the dominated
contracts
increases outputs that is to say if you
compare groups that were like on some
days offered those contracts compared to
other groups that
were randomly selected to be not offered
those contracts
on those same days they find that being
offered
this commitment contract increases
production by two point three percent
now you might say two percent is
actually pretty low um and that's true
in absolute terms that's not a lot of
money
but if you think about sort of what
other options does the employer have
well one thing you might want to do to
increase workers output is sort of
double their wages or just increase
wages overall now it turns out that like
um uh they also have some piece rate
variations that they can actually
estimate
how much of a peace rate increase do we
need to achieve these effects on
productivity
and it turns out the impact is actually
corresponding to like an 18
increase in the peace rate wage now if
you're an employer
you don't want to pay people like an 80
higher piece rate
for like a you know two or three percent
increase in productivity
that's just not worth doing it's just
like a bad deal i mean depends a little
bit on your costs and benefits of
production
but that's a very ineffective way of
getting workers two to
to to to be more productive and it's a
costly thing to do you're going to
incentivize a bunch of informational
people
uh to do that instead offering
commitment devices in the setting is
actually free
and in some sense for the employer you
might actually pay people less some
people don't treat your target you can
actually p
paid w over two now you actually don't
want to do that because you know workers
will be not happy and and you know uh uh
probably get annoyed with you if you do
that too much but
the technology is actually free here's a
thing that you can offer to your workers
they're going to be two percent or three
percent more productive
um that's actually a big deal for a lot
of companies in terms of the margins
often small
and a much better instrument in getting
workers to be more productive
compared to increasing people's wages
because wages obviously need to pay
any questions on that and then
a third and this is sort of consistent
with like a model of self-control being
really sort of the driver of this is
payday effects predict people's demand
for commitment i'm going to show you
this in a second
but essentially what they find is that
they're a they're payday effects what do
i mean by that
if you plot essentially products
production over the course of the payday
cycle
so here's on the very right hand side of
this graph you see people's
payday productivity compared to the
productivity on the day after the payday
or seven days before the payday
you see people essentially are more
productive on payday they produce more
on paydays compared to like previous
days
and so what you see essentially is like
a constant increase towards the day of
the payday
but somebody was asking me previously
about quasi-hyperbolic discounting or
hyperbolic discounting um
uh which models is right when you look
at this graph this actually doesn't look
very much like quasi-hyperbolic discount
it just
looks a lot more like hyperbolic
discounting as in like there's sort of
like a smooth increase
there's not like a jump up um uh on the
day of the payday people are more
productive
uh but it's rather sort of more
consistent with uh
true hyperbolic discounting that's more
of a detail here that's not that
important for you but i wanted to point
that out yes
that is a great question i think it's
production so i think um
this is not a this is not a great i
think these are units of production
i don't know exactly what the um
fraction is in terms of
production uh but it must be like a few
percent of production i can look this up
uh but it's like units of production
which is surely not what you want to use
uh here yeah and so then um
so so what we find here is that
essentially people are more productive
on paydays compared to the day after the
payday or compared to like six days
before the payday
um and then we find another graph which
is a quiz nice one which is to say
high payday workers or high payday
effect workers are more likely to exact
positive targets
what do we what i mean by that is they
split the sample into workers who have
high payday impacts and low paid impacts
that is to say
when you look at the workers and look at
like which workers are more productive
on paydays compared to
on other days you can sort of split the
sample into two some workers are much
more productive on paydays compared to
other days
some workers are not so what you see
here in the graph is you see essentially
the blue dots these are workers who have
high paid impacts
these are workers who are much more
productive on paydays compared to other
days
and you see the red dots which are
workers who are essentially
pretty much they have low paid impacts
meaning they kind of work the same on
paydays versus on other days
and then what they show on the so then
on the x-axis they show experience this
is like essentially
i think this is the course of the study
these are like you know something like
150 days
they have sort of different uh workdays
in the sample where like essentially
over time
uh people get to choose over and over
their targets
and what you see essentially is that uh
the blue graph
the blue dots tend to be a higher than
the red graphs
meaning that people have high payday
impacts these are workers of high payday
effects they're like more productive on
paydays
they're more likely to choose
positive targets so i should have said
on the y-axis you see
the fraction of people choosing positive
targets okay
so what we see essentially is two things
one is the blue dots are higher than the
red dots meaning that the people have
high payday impacts
they are more likely to choose positive
targets
sort of suggesting that so the
underlying reason why people have high
pay the impact is self-control you're
more more essentially
productive on paydays because you're
present bias one way or the other
and that also then predicts uh uh
whether you choose the target so people
have higher self-control problems as
revealed by the payday effects
those are the people who are more likely
to choose positive targets
second we also see um that the blue dots
tend to be
trending upwards in the graph you see on
the right the blue dots are higher than
on the left in the graph
meaning that as people have more
experience in the study when they have
like 100 150 days in the study
they're more likely to choose positive
targets consistent with some learning
about self-control
over time right so they learn over time
that choosing positive targets is a good
thing for them potentially that makes
them more productive
you don't see such a thing for the red
dots that seem to be essentially flat or
constant
over time so that was a lot of
information
are there any questions on that
yes arguably there's
lots to do with the salience of the pda
right so on the payday i have to come
into the office and do the work so i
might as well like type a little longer
to
earn a little more on other days you
don't really have that difference
you're not getting paid so there are
other jobs where like you get paid at
the end of the day
every day and then like you don't really
find the
paid effects and those dependent jobs
right
so exactly so there's an issue on like
when you think about these payday
effects
um what exactly do we learn from that so
one way to think about the payday
effects is kind of like the story i was
telling you which is to say
on days when you come in when you type
when you work you're going to be paid in
the evening and you work harder because
your
your reward is closer to you uh to your
effort
another explanation that you were saying
is like wow what if workers are just
like liquidity constrained what if like
their children are hungry etc and so on
so you come in on that day because you
want to work you want a paycheck
once you show up anyway you might as
well do some work and you're going to
end up being more productive
uh that way that's
surely in part going on that's sort of
two responses to that
so one response is like well we find
that the workers with high payday
impacts are more likely to choose
positive targets which sort of suggests
there's an underlying issue which is
self-control
problems that sort of like drives both
the payday effects and
sort of the high um the the positive
targets that people choose to demand for
commitment
second and more subtle in some ways is
like people are liquidity constrained
people who don't have cash
there's often like a reason why they
don't have cash which is often because
they haven't saved in the first place
now again that's a little complicated
but essentially um if somebody's very
liquidity constraints never has cash
often that's coming or the underlying
reason might be present bias or some
form of self-control problems to start
with
the reason being that like if you really
had such a value high value of having
cash you should just save it and have it
in your home or like try to like
save money on your bank account and so
on so usually we think that when people
are really liquidity constrained
often that's an underlying reason of um
present bias or some form of
self-control problems
having said that there's also some other
reasons why people can't save because
you know it might be they don't have
access to bank accounts
and so on and so forth
okay okay so
let me tell you one more application and
let me sort of
continue with the rest of those um uh uh
tomorrow
so this is sort of like a classic study
um in fact
done in boston and boston area health
clubs so this is de la vina and malmedia
and what they did is
they looked at health clubs and
different options that people did in
gyms
when they had sort of choices between
the following or the following kind
which is monthly fees of over 70 dollars
for unlimited use of the gym
or a pay-per-visit fee of uh 10
if you had that option or those two
options which options would you choose
or why would you choose one or the other
yes
right exactly so like why pay more than
why pick option
uh number one if you only go three times
um
uh when i was teaching the first time i
was doing exactly that in fact
um um but exactly as you say sort of if
you make like
if you understand how often you go to
the gym uh why choose
option one if you don't go at least uh
seven times there could be some
transaction costs
of the like but surely if you go only
once or twice you should not choose
option uh one now of course some people
might choose option one anyway why might
you do that
yes
right so one uh one one option is like
essentially change the
future prices so notice that the
marginal cost of going to the gym in
option two is like ten dollars
right every time you go your marginal
cost is ten dollars and option one the
marginal cost is zero
so what i'm trying to do is change the
marginal cost in the future
uh to make it more favorable for me
to go what else
could be going on so one is kind of they
could use this as a commitment device
what's another explanation
yeah over estimation
exactly it could be like essentially and
there's two versions of that one version
has to do with like beta delta or
present bias which is to say i'm just
underestimating my future uh present
bias i think you know my beta is like
one but in fact it's like 0.5
i think i'm gonna go 17 times but in
fact i'm going only twice
that's one option another option that
was also mentioned earlier was about
like underestimating the cost of future
exercising
that is to say what often happens when
people sign up for the gym
often they're already at the gym they're
like really excited to exercise and so
on
and they might underestimate how costly
it actually is once they sit at home in
the evening coming back from home from
work and so on they might underestimate
how it feels how costly it is for them
to actually exercise
nothing to do with self-control
specifically but it's just a tedious
thing to do they might underestimate how
tired they are and so on and so forth
with some form of like
underestimation of the cost that's again
hard to separate in many cases
but that could also be going on so what
they find then is people
exercise on average 4.3 times a month in
the first year that's about 17
per visit and of course you should be
choosing uh option
two before cancelling consumers go 2.3.1
uh
three months on average without using
your gym at all which is kind of like
you know it's even tedious to cancel the
gym
and actually go there and i did actually
exactly that as well
um so um how do you think about
quasi-hyperbolic discounting here well
so the gym
goers would like to exercise a lot in
the future be naive that's what they
think they will do so you know
overestimate what they will do
to save on gym costs um they buy the
monthly
membership that's kind of what the naive
person does when it comes down to
exercising their short run inpatient
kicks in
and they don't end up ending the
membership much that's very much like
sort of underestimating or
overestimating their beta or
underestimating the self-control problem
now what does a sophisticated person do
we already discussed that as well
which is they also prefer to exercise a
lot in the future but they realize they
don't want to
do so later so what they want to do is
they choose the monthly
contract as a form of commitment device
in a sense of like making future
actions uh changing prices in the future
they make it now
cheaper to exercise compared to sit at
home by sort of changing the marginal
cost in the future
and they might even be willing to pay
for that so they might actually say
i know that i'm only going to go like
three or four times but you know if i
don't choose that contract i'm going to
only go zero one times
and it's worth for me to do that
so now there's a different version of
when which one could do commitment
devices about um
dealing with temptation which is a very
clever
bundling of temptations paper by milkman
and others what they did instead of
offering commitment devices directly
what they did is they
bundle two things um i told you
previously about like investment goods
and leisure goods
and so investment goods are things like
going to the gym that you do not enough
of
leisure goods are things that you enjoy
in the present and you might be do too
much of
of that so now what you can do is you
essentially bundle those things so what
they did is they offer people
the option to only listen to audiobooks
addictive audiobooks
at the gym and so then you can only sort
of do that while you're at the gym and
you might come back to the gym not
necessarily because you want to exercise
but because you want to listen to your
audiobook
this can also backfire of a friend of
mine also in grad school
who was watching lots of tv shows and he
convinced himself that he can only watch
tv shows
while uh being at the gym so then i
would be in the office and he would
sometimes come back from the gym
totally exhausted because he had watched
like three episodes of certain tv shows
uh while being on the treadmill um and
you know so he was kind of like
uh over exercising because of his uh
consumption uh his bundling of uh um
temptations
but in this case for for so you have to
sort of figure out how to calibrate this
right
but it could be a way of getting you
essentially to by bundling essentially
pleasant
and unpleasant things at different
points in time by bundling them in
certain ways it might make you sort of
help you overcome
two issues at the time which is one you
go to the gym more often
b you might not sort of watch too much
tv if you can convince yourself
to actually follow through they do find
in fact bundling of temptation is
effective until the thanksgiving break
when sort of everything
goes downhill in their study okay that's
all i have for now i'm going to
continue on tomorrow with the remaining
parts of
time preferences thank you